[Applaus]
nichts kein einziger gesang keine
antwort mehr hören sie was ja sonst
nichts eine amsel im wald hier weiter
rechts war früher die feldlerche ganz
mal auf dieser seite haben hier ein
maisfeld
vielleicht tut es fehlen die kräuter der
boden ist kaum bewachsen hier hat die
lerche früher gesungen
auch dort und weit entfernt allein in
diesem umkreis gab es vier oder fünf
sänger wir sagen dem feldlerchen
territorien der eindruck täuscht die
landschaft ist ja immer noch grün
aber das ist nicht das gleiche grün wie
vor 60 oder 70 jahren ein sehr nettes
grün aber fast unbrauchbar für die tiere
[Musik]
georgi die aroma ist ein wandelndes
vogel lexikon der passionierte hobby
ornithologe war früher lehrer
[Musik]
auf diesen feldern in der nähe von
wilders begann er als 15-jähriger damit
vögel zu zählen
nehmen wir mal den zehnten mal 1953 als
ich hiermit meinen ersten beobachtungen
gartenrotschwanz mehrere oder hier fällt
schwer ein vogel den es in dieser gegend
schon viele jahre nicht mehr gibt die
schrieb noch vorsichtig mehrere dann der
drossel rohr sänger der größte aus der
familie der gras mehr viele
teichrohrsänger viele mönchsgrasmücke
viele dorngrasmücke ziele die ist von
dieser ebene völlig verschwunden tut
alles in diesem stil ich bewegte mich in
einem sehr kleinen umkreis und konnte so
die kleinräumige entwicklung der
vogelarten sehr genau mit was die
seltenere arten die spezielle
lebensräume brauchen werden überall
verschwinden wir müssen uns entscheiden
entweder überleben bestimmte tiere oder
es bleibt bald nur noch der mensch auf
der erde
[Musik]
45 prozent aller feld vogelarten sind
heute gefährdet
es sind genau die vogelarten die einst
dem schweizer mittelland weit verbreitet
waren
er kennt jeden vogel an seinem gesang
jahr für jahr beteiligt er sich halt
erzählung der schweizerischen vogelwarte
sein revier beginnt in diesem kleinen
wald bei waggon was hören sie relativ
kleinen zahl könig den hört man gut sein
gesang ist sehr klangvoll ein
interessanter vogel polygam und baut
mehrere nester die weibchen wellen eines
aus die waldvogel bestände sind eher
stabil
ich habe hier keine markante abnahme
bemerkt gegensatz zu den vögeln in
landwirtschaftsgebiet auch ein buchfink
in diesen tagen der häufigste vogel der
schweiz glauben wir dass alles in
ordnung ist weil wir immer noch der
buchfinken höher gewissem sinne schon
die vögel um uns herum so die die am
häufigsten vorkommen buchfinken
kohlmeisen und so weiter sieht man noch
oft vor allem im garten und im wald der
eindruck täuscht viele andere arten sind
dann verschwinden
gibt es keine vögel mehr
seit zehn minuten habe ich noch keinen
einzigen gehört am waldrand gab es
früher immer welche ihr im
landwirtschaftsgebiet suche ich sie
vergeblich nach protokoll an drei tagen
während der fortpflanzungszeit im
frühling dreht er seine runden
immer zur gleichen zeit auf einer fläche
von einem quadratkilometer
[Musik]
eigentlich ist das hier eine wüste ich
konnte mir gerade mal eine
vorbeifliegende krähe notieren
früher gab es hier 25 territorien von
lech lange es nur noch 14
die zählung besteht weitgehend darin
dass man die vögel hört und ihren gesang
erfasst
zwar macht er auch der gesang markiert
das territorium eines vogels in welchem
es seine jungen aufzieht unaufhaltsam
niedergang verschiedener vogelarten die
meine jugend prägt das ist sehr traurig
in der ganzen schweiz erheben hunderte
freiwillige daten für die schweizerische
vogelwarte sempach in der nähe von
luzern
[Musik]
in den letzten jahren wurden besonders
viele daten erhoben
für die dritte ausgabe des schweizer
brutvogel atlas dieser atlas hält seit
60 jahren die entwicklung der vogelwelt
fest verantwortlich ist biologe lukas
juni an der schweizerischen vogelwarte
für den brutvogel hat das sind über
2.300 flächen in der schweiz untersucht
worden
anstelle der üblichen 3 oder 20 das gibt
uns einen sehr guten überblick über die
verbreitung und über die dichte der
vögel je nach landesteil und auch über
die an zahlen und natürlich dann die
entwicklung seit den 70er jahren in vier
jahren
und jetzt also hier sehen wir die
abnahme in rot die zunahme in grün vor
allem eben die abnahme in roth von 35
vogelarten die auf das
landwirtschaftsgebiet als lebensraum
angewiesen sind
wir sehen dass es nur ganz wenige grüne
flecken gibt wie zb die champagne was
wir sehen das im mittelland in großen
teilen nicht viel passiert ist weil dort
diese vogelarten schon verschwunden sind
also die vögel die in den kulturen
selber ihre nester anlegen und die
nahrung suchen
denen geht es sehr schlecht also für
gewisse arten wie zum beispiel die
feldlerche und braunkehlchen da ist die
abnahme der region 40 50 60 prozent es
ist sehr massiv
das ist beunruhigend
das spiegel natürlich wieder wie wir mit
der umwelt umgehen wie die
landwirtschaft intensiviert worden ist
und insofern ist es ein sehr
beunruhigend das phänomen ein
eindrückliches beispiel für den einfluss
der landwirtschaft ist die ob ebene
wir sind hier etwa auf 600 meter über
meer
es gibt es auch noch schöne blumen
wiesen aber schlicht keine vögel mehr
also man hört noch einpacken
aber die vögel können nicht leisten weil
früher gemäß der berufsordnung junge
marie kämpft seit langem für den
lebensraum bestimmte arten wie wir den
des wachtelkönig der akut vom aussterben
bedroht ist
[Musik]
die meisten menschen nicht gefallen habe
hatten verstümmelungen ziemlich sicher
von mähdrescher und die weibchen werden
gleich nest getötet diesen vögel nisten
am boden das ist das große problem die
nächste sind also den
landwirtschaftlichen maschinen völlig
schutzlos ausgeliefert und werden immer
wieder zerstört
ich finde die lage dramatisch deswegen
reise ich auch so oft es geht ins
ausland im vögel zu beobachten
in der schweiz ist er schlicht zu
deprimierend vor allem im mittel spreche
nicht von den bergen wo es noch vielfach
gut aber im mittelland ist es für einen
ornithologen niederschmetternd wie große
teile des mittellandes ist die ob ebene
durch menschenhand stark verändert
worden
vor 150 jahren war hier noch ein
riesiges gebiet um das land nutzbar zu
machen wurden flüsse kanalisiert sümpfe
trockengelegt und partiellen
zusammengelebt der mensch ging derart
effizienz ursache dass in der schweiz
über 90 prozent der sumpfgebiete
verschwanden
heute herrscht intensiver landwirtschaft
vor auf solchen feldern finden vögel
keinen lebensraum mehr
[Musik]
es ist ein drastisches beispiel dafür
wie der mensch sich die natur zum
untertan macht jeder quadratmeter wird
bewirtschaftet
klar bei unserer bevölkerungsdichte ist
der druck auf die landschaft sehr hoch
dazu kommen die bekannten schweizer
tugenden sind fleißig und leisten ganze
arbeit
so hat die natur einfach überhaupt
keinen platz mehr
das resultat in den landwirtschafts
zonen ist fast jede zweite art bedroht
oder bereits ausgestorben weil
geeigneter lebensraum zur fortpflanzung
fehlt die vogelarten die noch da sind
sind etwas weniger anspruchsvollen sie
begnügen sich mit ein paar hecken am
feldrand um sie mit der kamera
einzufangen waren wir auf die guten
augen und ohren von lionel marie
angewiesen mit der nötigen geduld haben
wir sie gefunden
2 sie kommt näher sie wird sich genau
das fordert hinsetzen die goldammer ist
dann etwas fowler zugvogel denn nur ein
paar hundert kilometer selten auch 1000
zurück in dieser vögel sind zum teil
sesshaft
bleiben also das ganze jahr über ihr und
dann sehen wir einen neuntöter dieses
leichtgewicht fliegt zum überwintern so
weit wie ein langstreckenflugzeug mehr
als 10.000 kilometer manchmal bis nach
südafrika neuntöter gab es viel mehr es
ist nicht so lange her da waren sie
überall
heute muss man sie wirklich suchen sie
schließen ihre beute wie insekten oder
käfer aufstacheln auf damit sie lange
genug am leben bleiben um dann als
notproviant dienen zu können
das war jetzt gehört einer wachtel dort
in der hecke gleich hinter uns da sieht
man halt wie wichtig so eine hecke für
die nahrungssuche ist dort finden die
vögel insekten und unterschlupf einige
bauern richten auch mal kleine
naturoasen ein aber davon gibt es nur
wenige
[Musik]
die vögel verschwinden schritt für
schritt doch weil sie kaum noch jemand
kennt fällt es der allgemeinheit nicht
auf wer kennt denn schon das
braunkehlchen bekassine den großen
brachvogel oder den kiebitz dass wir
drei arten echte bürger verloren haben
bis nur die ornithologen die vögel
verschwinden vollkommen stillschweigend
[Musik]
naturschützer und experten schlagen mehr
und mehr alle zu fuss materie in la so
risch am neuenburgersee der uni theologe
und vogel zähler ist regionalleiter von
birdlife einer internationalen
vogelschutz vereinigung der rückgang der
vogel achten ist ein alarmzeichen den
augen schieber beim menschen ein zeichen
dafür dass im organismus etwas
schiefläuft dass man ernst nehmen sollte
die vögel sind wie ein thermometer
unserer umwelt das ist das gleiche
die vögel verschwinden weil unsere
lebensart mit ihrer existenz nicht
kompatibel
in der schweiz sind dreimal so viele
vogelarten gefährdet die weltweite und
klaas schweiz setzt die vögel unter
druck weil unsere lebensart nicht im
geringsten mit ihrem nachhaltigen schutz
vereinbar ist
laut naturschützern wie ihm ist unser
land wirtschaftsmodell das hauptproblem
dieses modell beruht auf
ertragssteigerung und ist abhängig von
chemikalien durch die risiken von
düngemitteln und pestiziden für die
umwelt sind eigentlich seit über 50
jahren bekannt
schon anfang der 60er jahre schlug eine
amerikanische biologin mit ihrem buch
der stille frühling alarm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
überall werden wahllos chemikalien
versprüht die nicht nur wie gewünscht
die schädlichen sondern auch die
nützlichen insekten töten die die vögel
verstummen lassen und die fische in
unseren gewässern töten
all das nur um ein paar kräuter und
schädlinge loszuwerden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
rachel kassen rüttelt ganz amerika auf
indem sie die toxische wirkung von
pestiziden wie ddt an den pranger stellt
die öffentlichkeit ist schockiert da ddt
zunächst als wundermittel galt
ddp an erfindung des basler herstellers
geige wurde weltweit im kampf gegen
mücken leuser maikäfer und andere
unerwünschte insekten eingesetzt
aber ddt ist viel gefährlicher als die
hersteller behaupten
[Musik]
es war ein stummer frühling die rede mal
ein dämmerung einst erfüllt durch den
klang unzähliger singvögel war nicht der
geringste gesang mehr zuhörer stille
herrschte in den feldern in wäldern und
den sümpfen
passage wieso also in seinen otto logi
vorlesungen erinnert fonds hat der ion
an die lehren aus der vergangenheit
indem er rachael kassen zitiert ende der
50er jahre war amerika ein großer ddp
produzent dieses bekannte pestizid das
durch seine giftigkeit großen schaden
anrichtet es konzentriert sich in der
nahrungskette die vögel am ende dieser
nahrungskette waren die welt beginnt zu
erkennen dass chemie nicht nur
fortschritt bedeutet dgt wird hat den
70er jahren in den meisten ländern
verboten
[Musik]
doch die produktion neuer pestizide geht
ungebremst weiter
in den neunziger jahren kommen
neonicotinoide auf den markt das
hochpotente gift ummantelt das sagt die
pflanze nimmt es während des wachstums
in sich auf und wieder zog giftig für
insekten besonders betroffen die bienen
[Musik]
die disney co wir verfolgen das seit
jahrzehnten an dem honigbienen
auswirkungen auf die fortpflanzung auf
das immunsystem er wird uns klar dass
das was für die honigbienen gut
erforscht ist auch für andere bereiche
im ökosystem zutrifft andere lebewesen
die säugetiere vögel reptilien oder
wasserlebewesen zeigen ähnliche symptome
wenn sie in kontakt mit neonicotinoide
kompressor manager deshalb dom eine sehr
beunruhigende entwicklung reagiert und
alexandre erforscht die wirkung der
neonicotinoide an der universität
neuenburg schon in kleinsten mengen sind
sie enorm giftig wenige gramm wirken
vermutlich fünf bis zehntausend mal so
stark wie ich habe das buch der stille
frühling gelesen es war schlimm zu
merken wir machen wieder die gleichen
fehler
wir wissen dass neonicotinoide für vögel
und insekten problematisch sind
verwenden sie aber trotzdem weiter gibt
es auch positive schritte die verbote
bestimmter substanzen aber wir sind weit
davon entfernt diese gruppe von
pestiziden prinzipiell zu verbieten
die auf das nervensystem der insekten
abzielt seit diesem jahr sind drei
dieser neonicotinoide in der schweiz
verboten
das bundesamt für umwelt folgte damit
einem beschluss der eu ein erster
schritt der schweiz die im
internationalen vergleich besonders
viele pestizide braucht
die schwarz sind landwirte in fünfter
generation kein bio aber hier werden die
pflanzen präzise und nur bei bedarf mit
chemie behandelt auf einer fläche von
über 40 hektaren im berner seeland an
diesem gerät kann man den dosierung
einstellen
genau was spricht sind vor allem die
fahrgeschwindigkeit mit dem doktor wie
thema kommuniziert die restmengen werden
wir hier kommuniziert sogar das fahrwerk
wird mir kommuniziert so dass die genaue
dosierung möglich ist wir spritzen jetzt
schon 20 prozent weniger chemie mit der
neuen technik peter schwarzbart
kartoffeln und verschiedene gemüse für
den großhandel an
das endprodukt muss doch sonst nimmt das
die große verteilung nicht teurer als
die frage stellt sich schon die wurde es
gemacht aber wenn man das produkt
abliefert ist stellt sich die frage in
diesem moment nicht dann muss es doch
sein
eine fliege oder ein fehler die mikro
getreten
bald wird er den betrieb seinem sohn
rose übergeben
bei uns war die ausbildung auf den
landwirtschaftlichen schulen komplett
produktionshaus gericht komplett
produktion mit remy mit und immer größer
und immer schneller dritte heute wird
das hinterfragt es in der betriebsleiter
schule bei ihm wurde gelehrt ökologie
mit intensiver landwirtschaft zu
verbinden
das ist eine neue art und das ist
richtig so
das ist das ist nicht ein trend das muss
so sein das wissen ja selber auch
aber das kommt wieder bei unserem
betrieb der spagat produktion perfekte
produktion und naturschutz
das ist nicht sehr einfach nicht einfach
aber die schwarz wollten wir es hier
doch versuchen seit zwei jahren arbeiten
sie mit birdlife daran den vom
aussterben bedrohten kibiz zu retten
einige paare haben sich bereit sie im
zuckerrüben fällt zum brüten
niedergelassen
ich bin franzose
und du macht martin zweig nicht martin
sind sie zu fliegen jahr wird sie sehr
zufrieden dass wir haben probleme in dem
ersten brut es hat nicht geklappt aber
die zweite brut ist erfolgreich beim
arbeiten auf dem feld dürfen die nester
nicht zerstört werden und die jungvögel
dürfen nicht mit pestiziden in kontakt
kommen für die landwirte bedeutet das
einen mehraufwand nicht bekommt
vorhinein können wir nicht so gut
ja wir sind zu wenig mit diesem metier
schwarzen schwan das kennen wir
ob pc diese spezielle folgen haben wir
nicht bekommen ja ich und mein vater und
ist das für den betrieben ein problem
oder eine eine chance oder es ist
interessant es ist beides ein wenig es
ist eine chance und manchmal ist es auch
etwas aufwand aber im grossen ganz
klappt die zusammenarbeit eher selten
klar ist nun zu und stefan ja für uns
ist es spannend wie ich habe jetzt in
den letzten zwei jahren sowie die
bevölkerung dazu gelernt wie vor und 18
jahren ich wusste dank dieser bemühungen
sind mittlerweile 20 bis 25 kibiz paare
in die region zurückgekehrt
[Musik]
die experten also die vögel beobachtet
wie man so schön sagt die werden bei uns
auch an einen bauern versammlung
eingeladen
und das ist sie ein quantensprung
das wäre vor 30 jahren nicht möglich
gewesen
zuerst mal muss zusammenkommen
bei uns ist wir leben von der natur und
der beobachtete hat seine freizeit in
der natur das ist so heute sind wir doch
ziemlich
mich beschäftigt wenn wir die
verschmutzung der nation sein sollen
wenn wir der naturschutz komplett
ausschalten würden das ist nicht so
natürlich wurde in der landwirtschaft
mit diesem gewaltigen schnellen
vielleicht zum schnellen fortschritt
fehler gemacht aber wer hat die fehler
nicht gemacht wohin sie nicht auch
gemacht
und doch der jahrzehntelange
pestizideinsatz geht als einer der
hauptgründe dafür dass es immer weniger
insekten gibt eine viel zitierte studie
aus deutschland spricht von einem
rückgang von über 70 prozent in den
letzten 30 jahren erschreckend und
wahrscheinlich auch in der schweiz
realität
[Musik]
dominic boeer ist philosoph
spezialisiert auf ökologie und
nachhaltige entwicklung muss sich
bewusst sein dass das aussterben von
tierarten früher sehr langsam verliebt
und hunderttausende von jahren dauern
nun haben wir es mit einer viel
schnelleren prozess zu tun
wir haben einen starken rückgang der
populationen nicht nur bei den vögeln
sondern bei allen wirbeltieren neue
studien zeigen dass in den letzten 30
jahren 57 prozent der wildlebenden
wirbel tierpopulationen verschwunden
sind
diese entwicklung ist beängstigend
vollalarm das ist keineswegs übertrieben
so etwas hat es noch nie gegeben und wir
wissen dass wir menschen dafür
verantwortlich sind und in der schweiz
ist es keinesfalls besser als im rest
der welt
ein blick in die roten listen macht dies
deutlich 79 prozent der reptilien 70
prozent der amphibien und 39 prozent der
säugetiere sind in der schweiz betrug
und auch unsere pflanzen und böden sind
unter druck
[Applaus]
wir machen hier auf zehn quadratmetern
eine umfassende erhebung von allem was
wächst in der ganzen schweiz gibt es
1600 50 solcher flächen aller ist einer
von etwa 100 spezialisten die an einem
projekt des bundesamtes für umwelt
mitarbeiten mit dem ziel zu beobachten
wie sich die biodiversität in der
schweiz entwickelt er arbeitet hier an
einem waldrand in der umgebung von
cherona an einem solchen standort findet
man normalerweise so etwa 40 achten
die pflanzen die an ein feuchtgebiet
erinnern aber auch solche die eher
typisch sind für nährstoffreiche böden
es gibt hier ein gutes dutzend gräser
achten die man nur anhand kleinster
unterschiede auseinanderhalten kann ein
blatt häuschen oder die behaarung zeigt
mir dass es sich um verschiedene arten
handelt das programm des bundesamtes für
umwelt wurde 2001 gestartet es soll
zeigen wie sich die pflanzenarten in
unterschiedlichen lebensräumen
langfristig entwickeln verantwortlich
für dieses projekt ist blendet
wer nicht gerade biologie ist meint wohl
das rundherum doch alles grün ist das
reicht pflanzen sind schließlich grün
und solange es um uns herum grün ist ist
auch die biodiversität da sie aber
beobachten ist eine verarmung der
lebensräume
wir finden immer öfter überall dieselben
arten zum beispiel der löwenzahn eine
typische verwiesen pflanze die
stickstoff- und dünger im boden lag
weil solche böden in der schweiz immer
häufiger werden finden wir den löwenzahn
heute auf praktisch allen unseren
biodiversitäts monitoring flächen das
ausmaß der verarmung ist riesig fast die
hälfte der natürlichen lebensräume in
der schweiz ist bedruckt das hat
auswirkungen auf die pflanzen dort und
es fragt sich ob sie auf dauer überleben
werden
[Musik]
wer wissen will wie es um die
biodiversität in der schweiz steht muss
nur die roten listen anschauen
sie zeigen wie stark eine art bedroht
ist in der schweiz stehen dort mehr
arten als in unseren nachbarn
insgesamt ist etwa ein drittel der
untersuchten arten mehr oder weniger
stark vom aussterben bedroht es geht
aber nicht nur um die tiere oder um ein
paar pflanzen auch wir menschen sind in
jeder hinsicht von einer natur abhängig
die im gleichgewicht ist
[Musik]
die werke sind auf mehreren ebenen von
der biodiversität abhängig sie erbringt
uns so genannte ökosystemleistungen das
beinhaltet alles aus der natur von dem
wir einen nutzen haben zum beispiel
saubere luft
wir vergessen gerne dass unser
sauerstoff ein produkt der photosynthese
ist die durch pflanzen geleistet wird
und uns das atmen ermöglicht es gibt
unzählige ökosystemleistungen zum
beispiel die bodenfruchtbarkeit sieht
man einen boden das leben so wird er
unfruchtbar
es gibt keine prozesse zur herstellung
von humus oder bodenfruchtbarkeit
wir brauchen die biodiversität für diese
leistungen die für das leben auf der
erde unabdingbar sind
die schweiz ist sehr gut darin wersen
diagnosen geht das bundesamt für umwelt
veröffentlicht berichte die zeigen dass
es der natur schlecht geht dass sie
leidet und dass die listen der bedrohten
arten immer länger werden und ist also
da durch die behörden ermittelt aber es
hapert an den mitteln für taten
der bund stellt nicht genügend mittel
bereits um den biodiversitätsverlust und
den rückgang der vögel zu strecken natur
und vogelschutz sind bestandteil einer
nationalen biodiversitätsstrategie sie
entstand im jahr 2009
ist aber der ganze acht jahre bis aus
der strategie ein aktionsplan entstand
während der amtszeit von bundesrätin
doris leuthard ja wir haben ein problem
darum haben wir diese strategie gewählt
den aktionsplan definiert und das budget
erhöht
und jetzt sind wir am umsetzen in zwei
drei jahren wird man bestimmt schon
positive resultate sehen aber das
braucht viel zeit klar die situation ist
wirklich alarmierend wir müssen handeln
und uns nicht mit dem zufrieden geben
was wir jetzt gerade tun aber könnten
sie als umweltministerin ja sagt nicht
eine höhere priorität einräumen
sie sind doch schon ein weilchen im amt
und das problem besteht ja auch schon
länger und dennoch bewegen wir uns im
schneckentempo oder gegeben es hat lange
gedauert bis aus der strategie der
aktionsplan entstanden ist schwierig es
gingen über 400 vorschläge ein
auch seitens der zivilgesellschaft und
der lg aus das war einfach zu viel
zudem ist das parlament im sparmodus und
will umwelt ausgaben kürzen und gut aber
ich habe trotzdem für die kurzfristigen
maßnahmen zusätzliche mittel bekommen
für die landwirtschaft oder das militär
bekommt man einfacher geld als für die
umwelt ebenfalls in der kritik stehen
die maßnahmen durch den bund zur
förderung der biodiversität in der
landwirtschaft
zu teuer und wenig wirksam die regeln
sind klar
die landwirte erhalten vom bund nur dann
direktzahlungen wenn sie einen teil
ihrer betriebsfläche zum schutz der
natur ausscheiden
umso präsenter hier haben wir unsere öko
fläche wachsen
sie liegt direkt am balkan douglasie im
frühling ecken wir dieses land einmal um
es etwas auszugeben
danach höchstens zweimal pro jahr gibt
es hier immer mehr blumen die einfach so
wachsen weil wir gar nichts tun auch
nicht denn wir müssen die partielle so
wie sie ist isabel sommer baut hier in
der nähe des bodensees auf 45 hektar
gemüse an
davon bleiben etwa vier prozent
ungenutzt
diese fläche haben sie wegen der direkt
an die oberfläche ist abhängig von der
größe des betriebs sich um patienten die
sich nicht unbedingt für den anbau von
gemüse oder ähnlichem eignen weil sie
zwischen der straße und den wald liegen
ziemlich klein und schwierig zu
bearbeiten sind
dabei ist unser chef
plötzlich sind schmetterlinge und
insekten wichtig bienen schmetterlinge
und andere insekten sogar wildschweine
rehe hasen und füchse leben hier
natürlich die natur ist sehr aktiv wenn
wir eine parzelle ein paar jahre lang in
ruhe lassen übernimmt die natur zeigt
uns dass sie stärker ist als wir
für maßnahmen wie diese zahlt der bund
jährlich 400 millionen franken das sind
14 prozent der gesamten direktzahlungen
doch in den über 20 jahren seit ihrer
einführung konnte man damit den rückgang
der pflanzen insekten und vögel nicht
stoppen
geschweige denn die situation verbessern
[Musik]
menge und qualität der vorgeschriebenen
öko flächen reichen nicht aus doch es
gibt auch landwirte die bedeutend mehr
tun als das gesetz von ihnen verlangt
das weiß auch philipp rogg ehemaliger
direktor des bundesamtes für umwelt
um die landwirtschaft mindestens hier
rundherum macht fortschritte
in den zwanzig dreißig vierzig jahren
seit ich hier bin ist es besser geworden
es gibt noch bauern die zu viele
herbizide einsetzen oder anderes aber
insgesamt haben wir hier mehr natur als
vor 40 jahren
und gewisse arten sind zurückgekehrt
dank einfacher maßnahmen wie kleine
ungenutzte wiesenstreifen sind bedrohte
vogelarten wieder zum nächsten da zum
beispiel das schwarzkehlchen der uvs
später oder die dorngrasmücke das
funktioniert sehr gut
was bisher getan wurde ist großartig und
wir müssen so weitermachen
es gibt nicht bloß die geschützten
flächen sie sind auch miteinander
verbunden
intelligent verteilt das sieht man rasch
einen fortschritt aber es braucht zeit
und natürlich bringen alle maßnahmen auf
den agrarflächen nichts wenn niemand die
halbe schweiz zubetoniert wird es ist
nicht nur die landwirtschaft aber dort
gibt es lösungen und die bauern müssen
unterstützt werden
aber wir müssen auch dieses wahnsinns
wachstumsstopp philipp rogg nimmt kein
blatt vor den mund
er kämpft mit überzeugung gegen ein
wachstum das von der natur entkoppelt
ist dieses modell funktioniert nicht
die welt hat ihre grenzen und wir können
nicht immer weiter wachsen
ein ewiges wachstum zu glauben ist eine
illusion
an einem bestimmten punkt ist schluss es
wäre besser nicht zu warten ist die
natur und stoppt weil es kein sauberes
wasser und nichts mehr zu essen gibt und
wir dann unseren nachbarn wegen des
letzten stücks schinken umbringen es
wäre klug ein leben im gleichgewicht mit
der natur anzustreben statt mit diesem
absurden system von wettbewerb und
wachstum weiter zu machen
ich glaube nicht dass
und können kein wachstum anzustreben
wachstum bedeutet nicht nur immer größer
bedeutet nicht die schweiz zu zu
betonieren
wir brauchen qualitatives wachstum
nachhaltiges wachstum nur kurzfristige
effekte die der wirtschaft helfen das
ist mir sehr wichtig und das kostet viel
zeit
da brauchen wir auch die unterstützung
der bevölkerung die den politikern sagt
abschluss jetzt versuchen anzeichen für
ein umdenken sind schon heute zu finden
aus diesen einfamilienhäusern umgeben
von den immer gleichen gärten und
rasenflächen sticht eines heraus die
grimms haben es gewagt die bürgerliche
ordnung in frage zu stellen
[Musik]
oder buffalo korda zuerst hatten wir
einen rasen mit allem drum und dran
vertikutieren im frühling und im herbst
düngen und eines schönen tages sagte ich
mir
nein das will ich nicht mehr das macht
dich ja wahnsinnig wir haben jeweils auf
allen vieren gänseblümchen und klee
gerettet weil wir glaubten
sonst würden bienen angezogen die die
kinder in die füße stechen
ich war ja mit ihnen aufgewachsen und
wir wurden auch nicht mehr gesprochen
als andere kinder eines tages
beschlossen wir also einfach alles
wachse so lanciert wir haben jetzt viele
insekten und mit ihnen natürlich alle
insekten fressen bei uns und es kommen
auch immer wieder schwalben im quartier
vorbei die grünes leben zu halten
auch hin lassen alle 22 nester sind
besetzt und erkor beiden haben etwas
mystisches magisches sie kommen von weit
her und finden ihr zuhause
das ist doch fantastisch letztes jahr
haben wir solarkollektoren installiert
und dachten die schwanken könnten unser
haus nicht wiederfinden aber nein sie
sind direkt hierher zu ihren nestern
geflogen
auch ornithologe lionel marie kämpft für
die vögel wo er nur kann setzt dass ich
ein für den erhalt oder die
neugestaltung von lebensraum im vallée
de joux setzt er sich dafür ein dass ein
paar meter wiesel nicht genutzt werden
[Musik]
wir befinden uns am oberlauf der ob hier
direkt hinter mir
auf beiden seiten des flusses wird auf
einem fünf bis zehn meter breiten
streifen seit etwa zehn jahren nicht
mehr gemäht
dank dieser schutzstreifen kann das
bauen kirche nie wieder nisten auch
sumpfrohrsänger wiesenpieper und
trojanern
nicht weit entfernt wird in der gemeinde
genie liebevoll ein fußgängersteg
unterhalten
die gemeinde will den holzsteg schützen
und eltern mit kinderwagen das
durchkommen erleichtern
so etwas treibt mich die wände hoch es
ist unglaublich
natürlich darf man wege unterhalten aber
nicht mitten in der nächsten zeit
sondern im september oder oktober wenn
die vögel weg sind wir sind hier mitten
in einem sumpfgebiet am rande einer
naturschutzzone solche dienste im sinne
der ordnung und bequemlichkeit haben
hier einfach keine berechtigung inhope
nooke notifikation
vor einigen jahrzehnten wurden devisen
noch im sommer von hand gemäht nicht mit
der perfektion von heute daher blieben
ein paar ungemähte stehen zurück die
reichten schon als zufluchtsorte für die
führung
man muss den vögeln nur ein kleines
bisschen platz lassen nicht noch den
letzten quadratmeter bewirtschafter
früher sagten die bauern sie würden
platz lassen damit die feen tanzen
können das fehlt heute ein bisschen mehr
platz würde das schon reichen für die
feldvögel ist es bereits fünf vor zwölf
zur erinnerung bei uns ist fast die
hälfte der arten bedroht dreimal so viel
wie weltweit
heute richten wir schaden an mit sehr
langfristigen effekt und mit nicht
rückgängig zu machen das sollte uns in
höchstem maße beunruhigen
europa hält uns aber kaum vom schlafen
aufgepasst ich sage nicht das sei
aussichtslos aber nur so etwas nebenbei
leicht machten
dem ist mit voller kraft systematisch
handeln und sein ganzes system das sich
über jahrhunderte entwickelt hat ist
betroffen
wir können nicht einfach die fassade
erneuern wir müssen das system im kern
ändern und das ist echt kompliziert
[Musik]
wir alle die wir unseren alltag oft
völlig losgelöst verbringen von der
natur jedoch unsere lebensgrundlage ist
müssten also vielleicht noch mal ganz
von vorne anfangen uns die zeit nehmen
und uns in einem der wenigen
naturschutzgebiete umsehen und lernen
[Musik]
regie führt nur für trips junge leute
früher habe ich einen trauerschnäpper
gesehen dem das verschwinden der
insekten sehr schadet gehüllt auch einen
wunsch spricht ein goldhähnchen und
einen schwarzen milan gehört habe ich
insgesamt rund 30 vogelarten um einer
solchen vielfalt zu begegnen muss man in
ein gebiet gehen das so vielfältig und
reich ist wie dieses hier in völlig sie
diesen ort oberhalb von vw behalten die
vogelbeobachter für sich ähnlich wie es
pilz am natur in den frühen
morgenstunden taucht kathrin in unsere
schweizer vogelwelt 1
die schöner farbiger und für uns lebens
wichtiger ist als wir es uns vorstellen
können der distelfink ist ein kleines
schmuckstück ein juwel mit spektakulären
farben die borussia ist durch die
umweltveränderungen stark zurück es ist
immer ein vergnügen seinen gesang im
flug zu hören
der so typisch ist wunderschön
im frühling vor ohne vogelgesang aus ein
paar krähen und elstern
stellen sie sich eine welt vor in der
alle diese farben formen und variationen
verschwunden sind
für den profit von ein paar schmarotzer
rischen arten wieder unsere eine welt
ohne natur wäre eine sehr traurige
düster rüttelt eine welt ohne musik und
eine welt ohne krise die ist nicht schön